[Music]  hi i'm television and film star harlan  williams as the great philosopher  frederick nietzsche once said god is  dead  but i'm not here to talk about god i'm  here to talk about my new champagne it's  called trader harland's sparkling fluids  it's a real champagne for real people  with real low amounts of money to spend  how do we make it so cheap  we use people with restless leg syndrome  their legs are twitching around anyways  why not have them fresh grapes  so the next time you've got a few bucks  to your name and you'd give anything to  go to that  beautiful place where butterflies smell  like margarine and  anteaters make a quality sex toy  give trader harlan sparkling fluid a try  you won't remember enough  you